eve-san Lal spent the better part of 28
years here in this room he sketched his
designs and held his fittings various
personal belongings lies strewn around
the desk as if he'd just left the room
the effect is intentional San Lawrence
former company headquarters has now
become a museum the concept is to leave
visitors with an authentic sense of the
place says Sabu's his chair of his
smoked the desk is full of things he
kept around all his life that were very
dear to him like the pot figures that
stand for his dogs we wanted it to be
more than a Museum of fashion more like
a place of remembrance and a historical
museum we're trying to recreate
something that doesn't exist anymore a
time when odd Kuchar played a major role
when collections were developed in a
very particular way oh okay the
collection features in certain many over
5,000 dresses complete with accessories
as well as sketches photos and films can
be found in the new museum's archive
beep seller all kept everything
including his very earliest creations
[Music]
this dress from 1962 was the very first
he made on commission for a client
museum goers can get up close to the
finest gowns
it's odd Kuchar at eye-level sano-sama
Wang was the first designer to archive
his clothes previously they used to give
them to the models after the fashion
shows or sell them straight to the
customers but he kept the original
prototypes so we can exhibit them today
he was also the first designer the stage
his fashion shows in other Lenox instead
about his Kuchar house in a hotel for
instance that made them an event and
they still are today in 2002 the first
rock star designer took his leave of the
fashion world with a grand show he
passed on six years later at age 71 in
2014 his partner both professionally and
in private Pierre Bouchet conceived the
museum project to bar J Yves Saint
Laurent was an exceptionally rare talent
do you know absolutely he left a
colossal legacy and is had a huge
influence on society
if fashion were about nothing but
creating a certain aesthetic and
addressing wealthy ladies he would have
no real significance but fashion has a
lot more than that it has a social
dimension same function socially the
hotel le could he fall to pieces from
men's fashion like the tuxedo or the
overall and transformed them and made
them wearable for women so the women
kept their femininity but they were able
to feel equal to men he latched on to
the tendency in the 1960s and held on to
it right up until the end of his career
to Torrance a car here whose condom into
among the French designers favorite
models was kyrat young the Indian model
first took to the catwalk for eve-san
are all in 1976
I mean hey at first glance IVA Celeron
made a very reserved and shy impression
on people but in smaller more intimate
company he could be completely different
he told stories and was good at
imitating people in general he was an
incredibly polite respectful person in
the 13 years I worked for him he never
acted like a star during fittings he'd
even asked me what I thought everyone
could have a say the Mon devanne IV
don't want party CP after the Paris
Museum a second eve-san law museum is
due to open in Marrakesh on October 19th
the fashion designer was born in Algeria
and spent a great deal of time in
Morocco an influence that could be
spotted in his creations
it delusion he originally came from
North Africa he grew up there that's
where he got that feel for color a
completely different feel than what was
normal for Paris at the time he favored
warm colors and strong contrasts like an
idiot
we also mix orange and pink simple so he
cooked quite at home in Marrakech it
reminded him of his childhood but Gus
said this on all false he obj will never
see the two new museums opened he passed
away on September 8th but his greatest
wish had been granted he's made Eve Sal
along the artist and visionary the first
fashion designer to have not one but two
museums devoted to him
you